have mercy is right chloe bailey of the
sister duo chloe and hallie finally
released her debut solo single have
mercy on friday and let's just say it
was worth the wait
yeah that's a 23 year old straight up
slaying every single second
not only is the song a bop but her dance
moves are a 10 out of 10. thank you
chloe also rocks some fierce looks in
the video like this diamond bra set a
pink hooded ensemble a long black gown
a gold bikini with a matching jacket a
baby pink underwear set a red dress and
then there's this skin bearing pink
beaded number i love it and don't blink
or you just might miss a cameo from tina
knowles lawson
yep that right there that's beyonce's
mom i'm just so proud of course miss
tina knows chloe and her sister halle
through beyonce who discovered them
after their cover of the grammy winners
track pretty hurts went viral on youtube
she later signed the duo to her record
label in 2015.
she is just
such an amazing person inside and out
you know being around her is just
amazing because
she's like just such a teacher to us
especially as young girls who are coming
up in this
music industry it's just so amazing is
it great to have a role model like that
who is
who helps you along and not just open
doors but also learn about life it is
such a great person to have in our lives
she's one of the top artists in the game
and she works so hard and puts 2 000 in
everything she does and that's very
inspiring to us and we hope to follow in
her footsteps one day
and after have mercy dropped tina shared
her support on instagram posting a clip
from the video
[Music]
so how does hallie feel about her older
sister's highly anticipated new music
it's out
clearly she loves it
i'll keep
the 21 year old little mermaid star
shared her support on her insta story
and posted this clip with her sister to
her main feed dancing and singing along
to the track
[Music]
oh